bonjour cette semaine à l'espace
philippe noiret je vous recommande parmi
le flot de films qui sortent un premier
film qui est la fête est finie de marie
gare et le vice
donc c'est un premier film très fort
vibrant et juste avec une énergie très
communicative
alors ce premier film est porté à
l'écran par deux superbes actrices
notamment zita enroe que vous avez pu
découvrir dans fatima c'était d'ailleurs
a eu le césar du meilleur espoir pour ce
film et puis clémence boisnard aussi
qu'on a découvert il ya quelques temps
ce duel qui va porter à l'écran
l'histoire d'une amitié fusionnelle et
une renaissance pour ces deux jeunes
femmes qui vont être confrontés aux
tentations du monde à l'extérieur et
sortir de cette toxicomanie avec toute
l'énergie qu'elles ont en elles donc
voilà un premier film fort et est juste
et dis moi juste la renault clio chose
n'importe quoi je vous demande rien
d'autre
pour deux est carrément impossible me
débrouiller je peux rien sans trois je
sais pas si je vous rends service
je crois que ça va finir comment tu veux
pas qu'ils ont gagné tous ils ont raison
de la création reste faible